maintenant les patrons sont quand même
depuis cette époque- là sont briefés un
bon chauffeur il doit se rendre compte
un petit coup dans le rétro s'il est
filoché il arrive le matin avant même
que son patron sorte deimmeuble il fait
un petit tour dans le quartier voir s'il
y a pas des véhicules suspects et dans
laffire en pain comme dans les autres
les chauffeurs auraient vu quelque chose
d'anormal et l'urait signalé à la police
et maintenant je pense qu'ils sont quand
même beaucoup plus
[Musique]
sensibilisés
c'est une histoire extraordinaire on
parle de parfois de de Pol de livre
policier de cinéma libérer le Baran
c'est la guerre céit
le capitaliste pur et dur le [__]
fini quand on enlève un monsieur qu'on
lui coupe le petit doigt et qu'on en
veut qu'à son argent bon je trouve que
c'est pas c'est pas très glorieux c'est
un type qu'on a respecté bien qu'on lui
a coupé un
doigt il a meurtri un homme il a cassé
sa vie il l'a mutilé donc il y a pas
d'excuse
[Musique]
il était l'un des plus grands patrons
français Édouard Jean ampin un baron
puissant un homme d'affaires flamboyant
à la tête du groupe ampin schnedre un
empire du bâtiment de la chimie du
nucléaire 150000 salariés à travers le
monde un matin de
1978 le Baron hampin est victime d'un
enlèvement contre rançon phénomène de
mode des années 6
[Musique]
ces ravisseurs récl une somme colossale
80 millions de francs et pour prouver
leur détermination il n'hésite pas à le
mutiler à lui sectionner une fallange de
doigt pour l'envoyer à sa
famille l'enlèvement du baron hampin
c'est un face àface impitoyable entre
voyou et liier du 36 qu des Orfèvres une
histoire d'argent d'amour de trahison
d'espoir et de
rédemption plus de 35 ans après cet
enlèvement que sont devenus Édouard
jean-ampin et ses
ravisseurs que pense le baron de ses
jaulier quel regard porte policiers
avocats et magistrats sur cette
affaire avec imali nous avons retrouvé
les protagonistes de l'affaire enempin
pour analyser avec eux les conséquences
et les répercussions de ce dossier h
norme tait 22h30 hier soir lorsque nous
avons appris que le baron Hin avait été
libéré par ses ravisseurs et libéré
saint et
sauf l'affaire commence 2 mois plus tôt
le 23 janvier
1978 ce matin-là le baron Édouard
jeanampin quitte son immeuble cossu du
16e arrondissement à Paris il est assis
à l'arrière de sa Peugeot 604 conduite
par son
chauffeur soudain des hommes armés et
cagoulés surgissent d'une camionnette
devant des témoins médusé ils nous
disent qu'ils ont vu n sa
fè des individus en sortir emmener le
baron de force et ils sont partis
précipitment l'enlèvement est rapide 45
secondes aussitôt un dispositif policier
est mis en
place les voitures sont fouillées la
ville est
cadrée mais le baron hampin et ses
ravisseurs se sont
volatilisés
Dian in la sœur du baron se souvient
encore de ce
jour-là comment apprenez-vous la
nouvelle de l'enlèvement de votre frère
la secrétaire d'éo rempin mon frère
téléphone à ma mère en lui indiquant
votre fils a été kidnappé moi j'ai réagi
à vrai dire je n'ai pas kidnapping je
comprenais pas très bien ce qui se
passait en en quelques minutes je l'ai
compris 2h après c'était un enlèvement
mais pourquoi comment vous êtes inquiète
inquiète je pense que toute personne
normalement constituée c'est avant toute
chose il faut libérer
l'otage le problème c'est que l'otage
est introuvable sa voiture la 604 est
retrouvée quelques heures plus tard
abandonné dans un parking à l'intérieur
aucune empreinte aucun indice pour
identifier les
ravisseurs les policiers de la brigade
criminelle dirigé par Pierre Ottavioli
prennent l'affaire en main le dossier
est suivi au plus haut niveau de l'État
car le baron hampin n'est pas n'importe
qui céta l' héritier d'une énorme
fortune c'était en même temps un ami du
président de la République de l'époque
Valérie giscardestin euh il faisait
parti aussi du groupe schneidre don la
femme du président était également
parente disons que c'était un gros
[Rires]
[Musique]
poisson Claude canè vous êtes
commissaire de police chef de section à
la brigade criminelle cet enlèvement à
l'époque il intervient après une longue
série d'enlèvements qui vont marquer la
France oui entre la fin décembre 75 et
le mois d'août
77 la France et le 36 queésorfire en
particulier va avoir à faire face à une
série d'enlèvements comme le transit na
jamais connu de l'affaire aan jusqu'à
l'affaire mé en passant par l'affaire Ré
bonment torov et une tentative
d'enlèvement autingre toutes ces
affaires ont tu un dénouement heureux
donc des enlèvements en France et puis
aussi des enlèvements ailleurs en Europe
oui surtout l'Italie c'était
l'enlèvement avec demandeçant était
devenu euh une industrie euh les
Brigades rouges mais le grand manditisme
et quelles sont vos premières pistes
après l'enlèvement du baron ben les
premières pistes dans toutes ces
affaires on on s'éteroche aux proches
les gens du groupe la famille et là on
est on est on est dès le départ un petit
peu dans le brouillard si ce n'est qu'on
sent assez rapidement que euh le baron
enin qui est le PDG du d'un des plus
grands groupes européens hein
manifestement autour de lui son
environnement euh euh n'est pas très
très très sympa avec lui on sent très
bien que euh bon il est parti il
reviendrait pas euh ça gûnerait pas
beaucoup
hein pendant que les limiers de la crime
explorent les premières piste le baron
enin lui est détenu par ses ravisseurs
il est séquestré dans des galeries
souterraines de loise sous une tente
dans le
noir bien entendu quand on est à
l'intérieur de la tente et enchaîné
on ne on ne sait pas ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur donc ça ça évite toute
tentation de de
[Musique]
s'enfuir Alain caayol vous êtes le
cerveau de cette enlèvement pourquoi
avoir choisi le baron en pin pour cible
le baron en pin ça a été en fait ça a
été une cible par défaut parce qu'on
avait fait une liste
et des hommes les plus riches de France
ou des femmes les plus riches de France
et pour diverses raisons on a éliminé
ces gens-là c'était qui les autres cible
c'était évidemment c'était Marcel
d'assau Marcel d'assau on l'a éliminé
pourquoi parce qu'il avait été déporté à
buenvald et que nous on était un petit
peu gauchiste et que on savait qu'il
était au mieux enfin pas au mieux mais
bien avec le Parti communiste et après
il avz Kilian bé
encour et vous avez renoncé aussi on l'a
éliminé pour des problème comme le le
l'endroit où on devait l'emmener il y
avait pas de
sanitaire pas d'hygiène pas de ceci on
s'est dit on va avoir sur les bras un
problème de de bonne femme ça va être
compliqué et en pin comment vous en êtes
venu à lui par la presse par par la
presse par la presse parce que cette
époque- là je vous dis c'était c'était
l'époque des quand la sérgie française
se cassait la gueule on avait appris
qu'ils avaient mis formmer des milices
patronales pour casser les syndicats et
les grèves enfin on s'est dit voilà
c'est le c'est le salot du coin c'est
c'est lui donc ce qui vous intéressait
avant tout c'était l'argent mais si
cétait l'argent c'était l'argent mais si
en même temps symboliquement on pouvait
rançonner un méchant capitaliste bon ben
voilà c'était c'était
parfait dès le lendemain de l'enlèvement
du baron Alain Cayol et ses complices
contactent l'état-major du groupe
eninchnedre ils exigent qu'un cadre se
rende à la gare de Lyon pour y récupérer
un message dans une
consigne là les policiers qui
l'accompagnent découvrent une demande de
rançon 80 millions de francs c'est plus
de 20 millions d'euros de nos jours une
somme
colossale mais il y a aussi un
mystérieux petit colis à l'attention de
la famille dans un paquet enroulé dans
du coton dans de la atte le bout d'un
doigt l'extrémité d'un
auriculaire c'est
rassurant parce que on va vous couper un
doigt pour négocier quelque chose ça
vous donne du temps dans une situation
comme ça vous craignez tout de suite le
pire donc tout ce qui n'est pas le pire
et mieux que le
pire pourquoi cette décision de couper
le doigt du baron nous notre notre
problème c'est que ça aille très vite et
comment ça peut aller très vite ben il
faut employer la terreur c'est-à-dire
vraiment marquer les gens et
effectivement on l'a su après
quand la police a reçu ça et les et les
gens de la direction de du groupe bah
ils ont peur c'est un moyen de pression
P voilà c'est un moyen de pression c'est
c'est c'est c'est rien d'autre qui s'en
est chargé comment est-ce que vous avez
désigné alors j'ai toujours répondu à
cette question c'est une décision
collective peu importe qu' a fait parce
que au moment où il a fallu le faire
pour pour poursivre le
plan chacun s'est regardé en
disant bon il y a eu un espèce de
silence on a dit allez courte paille
celui qui tour la plus grande ou la plus
petite c'est lui qui fait et on l' fait
comme ça mais c'est une c'est une
responsabilité collective vous l'auriez
fait si c'était tombé sur vous ah bien
sûr
oui comment le baron a-t-il
réagi alors le
baron silence radio
euh pas un mot pas une plainte rien
stoïcisme à la à la grec à l'ancienne on
s'est dit merde tu as vu ce mec il dit
rien il tient la route alors est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il a peur en fait non
c'était pas ça c'est parce que le
baronempin il est comme
ça face à la détermination des
ravisseurs les proches du baron hampin
comprennent qu'il faut réagir vite mais
comment réunir 80 millions de francs pas
simple d'autant que les avis divergent
sur la remise de çon on va avoir deux
attitudes différentes entre la famille
et le groupe le groupe va vouloir verser
la rançon de façon à essayer de nous
doubler ça c'est c'est clair et puis la
famille elle elle va être convaincue par
pierotavioli qu'il faut surtout pas
verser de rançon parce qu'on n'est pas
sûr du tout de retrouver
l'otage et puis si vous voulez il faut
il faut mettre fin à ce ce genre
d'affaire parce que comme je vous dis la
15e ça fait beaucoup quoi pourtant
malgré les instructions de la police de
ne pas verser de rançon des négociations
secrètes s'engagent entre le groupe enin
et les
ravisseurs on avait demandé une somme
ils nous ont proposé la moitié bon on
l'a refusé parce que on avait décidé que
c'était temps et pas et pas la moitié et
pourquoi vous refusez c'était quand même
une somme conséquente oui mais on parce
qu'on avait demandé 40 millions de
francs oui mais on vend pas le au
téléphone n on voit pas des tapis c'est
80 c'est 80 voilà vous jouez un peu avec
les ner de la famille et des policier ou
non non non mais non mais on veut pas
mais attendez on fait pas ça on joue pas
on joue on joue à rien du tout
euh s payent là si au lieu de 40 ils
apportent 80 il est il est libéré le
lendemain
voilà pendant ce temps les policiers qui
n'ont aucun indice sur les ravisseurs
décide d'explorer la seule piste qu'il
leur reste le baron enin lui-même et il
découvre la vie secrète de l'homme
joueur de poker habitué des casinos il a
perdu 11 millions de francs au jeu un
créencier mé content aurait-il cherché à
se venger en enlevant le baron ou bien
le baron s'est-il fait enlever lui-même
pour effacer l'ardoise comme on a
découvert que il était joueur bon on
pense à sous ce folklore du doigt coupé
chez les tricheurs là on s'est mis
vraiment à à creuser beaucoup mais ça ne
nous a pas apporté
grand-chose l'image du grand baron se
fit sur un peu plus quand la presse
révèle que le joueur est aussi un
coureur ses infidélités s'étalent à la
une des journaux la famille terrée dans
son quartier général de l'avenue Foche
est harcelé par la
presse on était terrorisé de voir ce qui
allait sortir dans les titres parce que
ça nous fait mal on a on a vu quand même
à savoir que la presse au 33 avenu Foch
avec un stetthoscope avait passé dans
une cheminée pour écouter ce qu'on
allait ce dont on parlait dans
l'appartement donc les choses sont
allées très très loin concernant la
presse le temps passe l'enquête pétine
et les huit ravisseurs du baron
commencent à perdre
patience c'est vrai qu'on s'est trompé
de cible au niveau des des liquidités et
de la fortune personnel on s'est trompé
on s'est trompé là-dessus alors après il
y a la lassitude il y a une partie de
l'équipe ouais mais moi j'ai pas vu mes
gosses depuis 3 jours euh moi on m'a
embouti ma bagnole faut que je fasse
changer le feu rouge moi je peux pas
garder après-demain moi ma femme elle va
chez le coiffeur enfin des trucs vous
avez envie de les flinguer et donc ça
vous pourrit l'ambiance vous avez envie
d'en finir vous en êtes venu à un moment
donné à voter sa mort bien sûr parce que
alors on le libère ou on le
tue on le tue pour l'exemple on en prend
un autre et là ça
paye simplement voilà cette question
elle s'est posée elle s'est
posée et alors ouis machin c'est salud
il faut le buter l'autre non on peut
quand même pas faire ça il nous a rien
fait en plus il est
gentil donc
vote 4 oui 4
non
revotei 5 oui TR moi j'ai voté sa mort
je vous avez voté sa mort
oui maintenant le tuer pas plus que le
mutiler franchement ça nous aurait pas
amusé c'était
pas mais en fait en tout cas moi je
l'aurais fait vous étiez prêt à le faire
si ça tombe sur moi on le fait alors
après on aurait retirer au sort qui le
fait puis voilà ça serait tombé sur
quelqu'un mais si c'est pas c'est pas le
but on veut on veut tuer personne
aujourd'hui vous êtes content de lui
avoir laissé la vie sauve bien sûr bien
sûr encore une fois il est jamais pr
c'est pas
prévu vous êtes content de de ne pas
l'avoir tué mais pour vous ou pour lui
mais pour lui et pour
moi de mois s'écoulent ainsi lorsque les
ravisseurs du baron fixent un
rendez-vous pour une remise de rançon
aux représentants du groupe ampin jeudi
23 mars 15h au fouets sur les
Champs-Élysées mais c'est la police qui
prend les choses en main l'inspecteur
maieri surnommé le chinois se fait
passer pour le porteur de rançon rançon
factice bien sûr sans suite un
interminable jeu de piste qui mène le
policier d'un café à un autre d'un
message au fond d'une poubelle au
suivant et bien on s'attend à tout sur
l'itinéraire à tout moment ils peuvent
m'intercepter il faut prévoir une remise
brutale une interception au cours du
trajet et pas forcément une remise en
douceur à un lieu de
rendez-vous ce petit jeu du chat et de
la souris dure plusieurs
he il est escorté à distance par ses
collègues de la Brigade de Recherche et
d'inv
l'antigang Robert Broussard à l'époque
vous êtes le Patron adjoint de la BRI
comment faites-vous pour monter le
dispositif qui va protéger Jean maieri
lap qui doit remettre la ronçon c'était
très lourd c'était très lourd disons que
j'avais à peu près 20 25 gars de de la
berie avec moi il y avait des gens qui
étaient à moto véhicule camionnett
différents véhicule de toutes sortes
complètement banalisé avec des tenues
complètement également banalisé où on
devait faire semblant de s'ignorer no
gars a été vraiment formé à à ce travail
de filature de surveillance mais c'est
nerveusement c'est extraordinaire au
point de vue fatigue quels sont les
risques d'une telle opération mais les
risques d'abord c'est c'est se faire
remarquer par les les preneurs de Tage
et il est évident que quand on nous fait
faire tout un parcours il se place à des
endroits pour voir si le porte de rançon
est suivi ou pas donc c'est le jeu du
chat et de la souris maisellement ouais
mais vous vous n'avez pas la main voilà
on est on est là devant le faitte
accomplli un petit peu l'itinéraire on
ne connaî pas laavance et surtout c'est
que je m'excuse du terme mais on voit
des des suspects partout hein mais tout
cela c'est c'est j'allais dire c'est
quand même extrêmement crispant parce
que vous n'êtes sûr de rien
voilà le jeu de piste dure 2 jours
policiers et ravisseurs sont à Bou de
ner dernière étape l'autoroute à6 les
ravisseurs fixent rendez-vous au chinois
près de la bandne téléphonique B16 au
sud de
Paris l'inspecteur Eric Jung est au
première loge il est alors policier à
l'antigang chargé de protéger maierie
alias le chinois qui se gare près de la
borne
téléphonique le chinois descend mais à
ce moment-là dans le même temps tout ça
dans le même temps on voit je vois
jaillir sortir comme sortir de la terre
de hommes cagoul d'un côté tenant des
grenades de l'autre côté tenant un
pistolet mitrailleur et qui passe par le
monticule qui arrive à la bne
B nous on déboule comme de fou du talu
on monte dans sa bagnole on s'en
va fait 4 km
à Al et son complice arrivve à hauteur
du mur antibruit de l' rose poursuivi
par les policiers de la crime et de
l'antigang là tout bascule pourquoi
parce que tout en haut du mur de
l'autoroute il y a un Truant qui est là
avec un pistolet mitrailleur et là il
ouvre le feu et c'est une fusillade
comme j'en avais jamais vu jusqu'à
maintenant et ça pète de
partout et mon copain dans ces quelques
secondes se prend une balle dans le dos
à traversavers
[Musique]
la moi je lève les mains et ça continue
à tirer donc je prends deux balles dans
le
bras évidemment là les frcs arrivent
sortent mon copain qui meurt là et moi
je suis à poil complètement à poil il y
avait je dirais presque cette odeur de
poudre noire et de sang qui coulait et
je me suis précipité vers l'homme qui
était par terre j'ai pris mon arme j'ai
armé le chien et je lui ai mis avec le
chien armé mon revolver dans la bouche
en le menaçant de le tuer s'il nous
révélait pas où était le baron à pin et
je lui ai dit tu as vu ton copain il est
mort il a été tué si tu nous dis pas où
il est je te bute et la personne qui est
par terre le voyou qui est par terre me
regarde les yeux dans les yeux et ne dit
rien évidemment j'allais pas le
tuer Alain caol est pour vous la seule
piste qui permet de retrouver le baron
il faut ent que Kol parle comment ça va
se passer Kol qui est un type
intelligent a bien compris
que l'enquête étaé un point tel qu'il
fallait que le baron soit libéré or son
gros souci c'est qu'il savait que parmi
les ravisseurs il y avait ge
Bertoncini ce que redoutait alin col
c'est que
Bertoncini pour venger son copain du
château qui avait été tué lors
d'inpellation la fusillade ne tue à son
le Barin et il dit àoli voilà moi je
suis prêt à téléphoner pour faire
libérer le bar dit vous avez un
téléphone là sur son bureau et je revois
la scène comme si c'était hier il prends
le
téléphone le rapproche comme ça cache le
combiné et fait le numéro je crois
pouvoir dire mot pour mot ce qu'il a dit
libérer le Baran c'est la guerre
le coup de fil d'Alain caayol va
payer après 63 jours de captivité le
Baron hampin est enfin
libéré pour moi c'était miraculeux
c'était magnifique le travail qu'avait
fait la criminelle il était libre
maintenant respect il demandait qu'une
chose c'est de rentrer chez lui voir son
chien son épouse ses enfants et dire je
suis
libre Jean-Edouard hempin est libre mais
stupéfait et déçu au plus haut point par
l'accueil qui lui est réservé car
entre-temps les révélations de la presse
sur ses frasques ont terni son image sa
femme et ses collaborateurs lui tournent
le dos je métais dans des rêves fous
imaginer que quand j'allais revenir
c'était le retour de Monte Cristo il va
y avoir du monde au balcon il va y avoir
tout le monde était là avec la bouteille
de champagne le truc le machin youi
comment on y va je m'étais
imaginé une
fête je vois que tous les gens une mine
frant c'est une suspici et cetera
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il va falloir
que tu t'expliques il va falloir ceci il
va falloir cela expliquer mais expliquez
quoi côté police après le retour du
baron l'enquête progresse rapidement une
bonne partie de la bande des ravisseurs
est arrêté dans les mois qui suivent h
personnes en tout 6 hommes et deux
femmes 4 ans plus tard le 2 décembre
1982 le procès s'ouvre la vedette de
l'audience c'est le baron sa déposition
à la barre marque les esprits il va
raconter exactement les faits tels
qu'ils se sont déroulés et c'est sans
doute le réquisitoire le plus lourd
qu'il pouvait faire contre eux sans
haine euh sans
exagération sans donner du romanesque à
quelque chose qu' ne n'en avait pas et
euh là il a une une attitude où vraiment
il se réhabilite si réhabilitation il
devait y avoir c'est peut-être pas le
bon mot mais il il il fait basculer son
image vers un aspect positif
nien ni désir de vengeance le baron
pardonne à ses ravisseurs après 3
semaines d'audience les peines de prison
s'chelonnent de 5 à 20 ans 20 ans c'est
la peine dont a écopé Alain col qui
était pourtant défendu à l'époque par un
ténor du Barau futur ministre George
kgem j'avais cette candur de penser que
là où je passais la sévérité trèpassa
non non
a quand même été condamné à 20 ans ce
qui était pas rien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui 37 ans après l'enlèvement du
baron hempin cette affaire reste unique
car c'est le seul enlèvement où le
retour s'est avéré plus difficile pour
le prisonnier que sa
captivité pourtant quelques jours
seulement après sa libération le baron
envisageait de reprendre sa vie comme
avant je lui demande mais monsieur le
baron ça va se passer comme pour vous
maintenant surtout qu'il avait
énormément souffert avec un sourire
extraordinaire il me regarde et me dit
mais vous saveis ça va rien changer pour
moi tu savis je suis né avec une
cuillère d'argent dans la bouche et les
choses vont s'effacer le temps va passer
et je continuerai à vivre comme j'ai
vécu avant et ça ça m'a laissé j'ai dit
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible et
c'était pas moi qui me trompé c'était le
baron
in après son retour le baron Hin se met
au pendant 8 mois loin de chez lui envie
de décompresser et de se reconstruire il
est parti aux États-Unis avec un de ses
vieux amis d'enfance et puis il est
revenu en France et là il a dit je
reprend la direction des
affaires mais le baron flamboyant a
perdu de sa superbe et sa légitimité est
contesté à la tête de son propre
groupe le fait que je sois pas là fait
des
ce que j'appelle des des appels d'air
pour beaucoup de gens ils ont donc
voulu certains prendre ma
place d'autres prendre la place de ceux
qui prenaient ma place c'est-à-dire que
toute la hiérarchie qui voulait monter
d'un cran
et fallait surtout pas que le baron
revienne qu'est-ce qui allait se passer
tout le monde devoir re baisser d'un
cran
le Baron est poussé vers la sortie
conséquence d'un enlèvement dont il
n'est pourtant que la
victime vous avez pris conscience à ce
momentl du mal que vous aviez fait à cet
homme non seulement physiquement mais ai
psychologiquement et socialement aussi
ouiah oui parce que moi donc on avait
les journaux les journaux oui en fait on
l'a tué là il était détruit vous l'avez
détruit ouiou bien sûr on détruit bien
sûr on lui a [__] sa vie
professionnelle et peut-être une partie
de sa vie sociale
oui et ça vous vous le vivez
comment
aujourd'hui ah c'est tombé sur lui
voilà en 19 81 le baron vend les parts
de son groupe l'héritier toutpuissant
repart de
zéro une espèce de rage le saisit et
tout d'un coup il décide de vivre pour
lui en quelque sorte hors du personnage
qu'on avait fabriqué jusque là pour lui
l'ancien capitaine d'industrie devient
alors petit patron il se lance dans
l'import-exort de matériel aéronautique
et dans l'immobilier oh il a appris que
euh la trésorerie d'une petite
entreprise c'était difficile à à à gérer
que il fallait faire attention par
rapport au groupe Rud d'Anjou enfin
c'était quelque chose de d'assez peu
imaginable mais je franchement il s'est
il s'est bien fait le baron ne
retrouvera jamais le succès dans les
affaires il est même jugé pour banqurout
en
1998 il a été relaxé de de la bancroute
que l'on lui reprochait mais ça n'a pas
été facile
effectivement pas facile non plus côté
famille les révélations dans la presse
ont fait du mal son couple se
délite de toute façon j'ai été décrit
comme un espèce de noseur
mondain joueur à peine honnête avec des
relations douteuses qui faisaaient des
parties de poker dans des tripas
d'arrière salalle ma femme me l'a pas
dit mais m'a fait comprendre que on peut
pas on peut pas avoir
euh mes enfants peuvent pas avoir un
père comme ça il divorce avec la
princesse Sylvana qui était sa femme et
et euh qui dont il enfin il ils étaient
tous les deux très épris l'un de l'autre
avant mais la révélation d'un certain
nombre de choses a fait que que ça
n'était plus
possible
l'affaire du baron hampin reste
emblématique dans l'histoire de la
police elle a marqué l'histoire du 36 qu
des Orfèvres tout d'abord parce que
c'est le rapte le plus long jamais connu
en France mais aussi parce que la
stratégie de fermeté de la police a payé
pierre Ottavioli le patron de la brigade
criminelle avait décidé seul de ne pas
verser la
rançon Claude canè pourquoi décider dans
une affaire d'enlèvement qu'il n'y aura
pas de remise de rançon tout simplement
parce que Pierre
avioli avait compris que si on cédait
une seule fois au ravisseur à ces grands
grands voyou c'était fini on ne
maîtrisait plus rien et que il dit
souvent il a dit souventioli les voyou
n'ont qu'un objectif l'argent l'approche
de la de la rançon va leur va leur faire
recommettre des des imprudences et en
même temps c'est un peu facile pour la
police de dire on ne P pas mais la
police prend aussi le risque de mettre
en péril la vie de la vie de l'otage oui
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr c'est un
risque c'est un risque mais queoli a a
pris et encore une fois qu'il a pris
tout seul parce que qu quand on dit que
je dis que sa hiérarchie administrative
et donc politique et
judiciaire ét d'accord avec sa sa
stratégie c'était un accord mais allez
soyons clair du bout des lèvres
après une longue série d'enlèvements
dans les années 70 Édouard jeanempin a
été le dernier patron kidnappé le
dernier sur le territoire de la police
judiciaire
parisienne car après lui deux autres
patrons ont été kidnappés en
France il y a eu l'enlèvement de Henri l
lièvre qui était un banquier
milliardaire qui habitait dans la Sarte
et qui a vu un jour débarquer deux
policiers chez lui qui se sont révélés
bien sûr des faux policiers parce que
c'était Merine il avait demandé 6
million de francs qu'il a obtenu et puis
l'autre enlèvement qui ressemble un peu
à ça c'est jacqu ver alors qui était un
petit voyou qui dans les charantes
enlève un PDG d'une grosse tuilerie Maur
Ribière alors là on descend encore lui
demande 3 million de
francs Michel Mor Ribière a été libéré
sans remise de rançon avant que son
ravisseur jacquesver ne soit arrêté
condamné à 20 ans de prison
quant à Jacques Merine il n'a pas
profité bien longtemps de sa rançon 3
mois plus tard il est abattu par la
police porte de clign en court à chaque
fois la police a gagné même si à
l'époque elle travaillait avec des
moyens qui aujourd'hui peuvent semblit
parfaitement
desuet nous avions des véhicules
banalisés vraiment très repérables et
des tokiwalky assez peu fiables
maintenant avec les téléphones portables
avec les balises euh les GPS ce serait
effectivement beaucoup plus facile là on
se repérait sur des petits plans de
banlieu qu'on avait dans dans la main
c'était quand même assez
compliqué d'autant que dans une affaire
d'enlèvement les premières heures sont
capitales à la fin des années 70 la
recherche d'information sur la victime
n'était pas ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous allez
prendre internet et sur le net vous
allez avoir tout le curriculum vité de
ce monsieur des photos des adresses ses
relations son groupe vous pouvez aller
chercher dans le groupe enfin en
quelques minutes vous avez une masse
d'informations nous à l'époque on avait
un vieux wevous euh dans le bureau du
directeur de la PJ trois étages en
dessous et puis autrement euh ben il
fallait envoyer une équipe euh dans la
famille pour essayer de de d'en savoir
un peu plus on envoyait une équipe à la
société on appelait les renseignements
généraux et la DST et on avait les mêmes
renseignements que sur internet mais en
une demi-journée quoi si l'enlèvement du
Barron en pin se passait aujourd'hui
comment est-ce qu'on procéderait
techniquement au niveau de la police
scientifique alors déjà assez rapidement
je pense une partie de la bande sera
identifiée pourquoi parce que dans les
véhicules qui ont été abandonnés
l'estafette volée la voiture du baron en
pin les techniciens de la police
technique et scientifique on retrouvé
des petits cheveux des traces sur
lesqueles on peut trouver des ADN des
relevés de traces papillaire et comme
tous ces gens-là étaient connus fichés
on aurait identifié certainement
plusieurs membres de de la bande assez
rapidement quel autre moyen les caméras
Paris il y avait aucune caméra dans dans
dans Paris à l'époque maintenant je peux
vous dire que on aurait vu certainement
la la le trajet d'une partie du du
convoi on aurait plus rapidement
identifié certains MAM d'Alban ce qui
veut pas dire qu'on les aurait arrêté
euh euh aussitôt ça c'est une une autre
paire de manche mais ça nous aurait déjà
mené sur une piste intéressante est-ce
que ce serait aussi facile aujourd'hui
d'enlever un patron comme ça l'a été
quand on a enlevé le baron en
pain beaucoup plus difficile pourquoi
maintenant les patrons sont quand même
depuis cette époque là sont briefés il y
a non seulement des services officiels
je pense à la djci la ancienne DST et
cetera et même des des entreprises
privées qui vont dans les entreprises
pour donner des conseils non seulement
au patron au chauffeur pour faire en
sorte que ils aient leur attention
éveillé un bon chauffeur il doit se
rendre compte un petit coup dans le
rétro s'il est filoché il arrive le
matin avant même que son patron sorte
deimmeuble il fait un petit tour dans le
quartier voir s'il y a pas des véhicules
suspects et dans la faire en pain comme
dans les autres les chauffeurs auraient
vu quelque chose d'anormal leurit
signalé à la police et maintenant je
pense qu'ils sont quand même beaucoup
plus
[Musique]
sensibilisés du côté des ravisseurs 37
ans après l'enlèvement du baron les
rangs se sont
clairsemés Alain caol est l'un des seuls
survivants sont Mor de vieillesse de
maladie de de de banditisme voilà ils
sont morts des années de
placard la pauvreté la maladie la
vieillesse pas
sympa parmi les disparus George
Bertoncini proenet et trafiquant
marseillais qui avait éécopé de 15 ans
de prison pour la séquestration du baron
libéré en 1989 il replonge 5 ans plus
tard pour trafic de cocaïne entre la
France et la Colombie il est mort en
prison en
2001 mais la justice n'a pas jugé tous
les ravisseurs du baron hampin car trois
d'entre eux ont échappé aux poursuites
l'un d'eux toujours vivant coule des
jours tranquille koayol ne l'a pas
balancé alors je vais pas vous demander
son non non de toute façon c'est périmé
c'est un rescapé et c'est c'est un
garçon en plus qui a pas de casier
judiciaire qui n'en a jamais eu qui en a
jamais eu
euh et qui après ça
euh a refait sa vie voilà il a eu une
période il était très jeune du
reste un peu
chaude il a eu beaucoup de chance voilà
il y a des gens qui sont éjectés de
l'avion avant qu' quand il crache quoi
voilà et puis bah le mec il a été éjecté
de l'avion et comment est-ce qu'il est
passé entre les mailles du filet il pas
identifié et personne l'a donné et
personne l'a donné voilà et que fait-il
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il travaille à
l'étranger ça va pour
lui Alain Cayol est libéré en
1989 après 11 ans de prison 11 années
pendant lesquelles il s'est intéressé à
la littérature il publie alors un livre
sur la correspondance ge Sand écrit en
détention cette nouvelle carrière
d'écrivain lui permet de recroiser la
route d'une vieille
connaissance le policier qui lui a mis
le canon de son arme dans la bouche pour
le faire avouer 15 ans après c'est après
avoir effectué sa peine voilà que lui
fait un livre que moi j'ai quitté les
flics et je suis journaliste à France
interre et qui va être mon invité de
plateau pour une émission
enregistrées de émission Alain caol ne
reconnaît pas Eric Jung le flic
reconverti en
journaliste à la fin je lu dis monsieur
Cayol on se connaît tous les deux il me
dit ah bon on se connait ben je lui dis
oui vous parlez même de moi dans votre
livre page 103 et là je vois la tête de
CAO qui change et dit mais c'est pas
possible vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas
vous n'êtes pas le flic qui je dis si
mais me dit mais c'est vous je dis oui
mais vous marquez dans votre livre je
savais qui n'aurait pas tiré et à quoi
vous l'avez su il me dit parce que j'ai
vu dans je l'ai lu dans vos yeux et
depuis j'ai gardé des relations
euh amical n'est pas le mot mais des
bonnes relations avec un la caayo que je
revois
régulièrement après quelques années de
vie tranquille Alain Cayol replonge à
son tour en 2001 pour trafic de
cocaïne décidément pas facile de se
ranger je dirais que j'ai un agacement à
voir que Cayol à replongé c'est un peu
dommage que finalement il ait jamais vu
d'autres moyens de réaliser ses
ambitions que de tomber dans dans les
infractions euh parce
que au fond j'aurais bien vu col comme
maîre de conf dans université un peu
trop enclin à regarder avantageusement
ses étudiantes et menant une espèce de
vie de de Dandi quoi il y a aucune
cruauté chez Cayol quand il joue les dur
il se force un peu le braqueur amoureux
des belles lettres refait 5 ans de
prison et sort en 2009 3 ans plus tard
il publie son deuxème livre lumière
c'est le titre de sa vérité sur
l'enlèvement du baron
hampin je voulais lui demander pardon
collectivement au nom de
tous comme lui il l'a fait parce que euh
généralement bon les gens qui sont des
malfaiteurs qui ont des victimes ils
font la puis ils s'en foutent moi je
j'étais
désolé désolé que ça soit tombé sur lui
désolé qu'on lui a bousillé sa vie voilà
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je lu dise
de plus j'étais je suis
désolé ce qui est vrai ce qui est vrai
dans votre livre vous avez parlé de
syndrome de Stockholm inversé qu'est-ce
que vous entendez par là
c'estàdire que le temps passant en pain
étant dans une tente
et un tel lui donne à manger un tel à
boire une cigarette enfin bon des liens
secrets et puis on discute fais du
tennis fais du ski tu sors en
boîte tu chopes des
gonzesses bon et en fait en pain il
représentait l'idéal
des mecs qui étaient là
être jeune être beau être riche
être voilà tout ce que tout ce que vous
vouliez tous tout ce qu'on voulait tous
donc il y a eu avec le respect une
espèce d'admiration comme comme les gens
qui qui admirent des stars de cinéma
vous avez rencontré le le baron enain à
l'occasion de la sortie de votre livre
c'est un moment d'émotion quand je l'ai
vu ah oui bien sûr alors si vous voulez
une anecdote
quand on l'a pris et que je lui ai lu ou
donné nos
conditions je l'ai tutoyé d'entrée et je
l'ai toujours tutoyé quand il était en
détention aujourd'hui j'arrive pas à le
tutoyer je peux j'arrive pas j'arrive
pas alors quand vous parliez de respect
ça doit être ça j'arrive pas à le
tutoyer c'est un espèce de Seigneur en
pain parce
que il il vous reprochera jamais rien
il il est au-dessus il est c'est un type
pour ça il est
[Musique]
impressionnant Dian enin que pensez-vous
de des excuses d'Alain Cayol à votre
frère j'ai pas
d'excuses pour moi il
a il a meurtri un homme il a cassé sa
vie
il l'a mutilé donc il y a pas
d'excuse il a
euh changé une famille donc
j'ignore le silence engendre le
mépris vous regrettez aujourd'hui je
regrette rien du tout de ce que j'ai
fait simplement la bonne question c'est
si vous pouviez recommencer votre vie
est-ce que vous referez pareil voilà non
effectivement si céit à refaire voilà si
c'était à refaire je ferais pas de
délinquence et pas de banditisme
aujourd'hui parce que aujourd'hui je
sais des choses que je savais pas mais
euh voilà moi j'assume ma vie comme elle
a été comment vivez-vous aujourd'hui
livre
internet théâtre un petit peu puis voilà
ciné ça vous voit comme vie
parfait parfait moi je suis un petit
retraité à la con euh je suis pas ce que
j'aurais souhaité ou voulu être et voilà
c'est comme ça vous êtes un retraité
tranquille tranquille oui tranquille
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire tranquille
jeis je suis plus un malfaiteur voilà si
c'est ça que voulais
[Musique]
dire l'affaire en pin a fait couler
beaucoup d'ancre au moment des faits
elle a suscité des passions et reste
ancré dans la mémoire criminelle des
Français nous devons mettre toutes les
armes de notre côté souvenir ravivé en
2009 lorsque le réalisateur Lucas belv
porte à l'écran une adaptation largement
inspirée de l'enlèvement du baron en
pint
allô le scénario ressemble beaucoup à
l'affaire mais c'est une transposition
contemporaine le personnage principal
joué par ivant hatal s'appelle Stanislas
Graf Lucas belevud pourquoi avez-vous
décidé d'adapter cette histoire au
cinéma parce qu'à l'époque du du rapte
j'étais euh assez jeune j'étais
adolescent et finalement j'avais pris ça
un peu à la légère en me disant ouais
finalement un grand patron exploiteur et
cetera il a eu ce qui ce qui méritait et
en revoyant après le le baron raconter
son histoire raconter sa captivité je me
suis dit mais ce que cet homme a a subi
euh c'est c'est épouvantable on ne peut
le faire subir à personne donc je me
suis dit il faut faire un un film pour
montrer ce que c'est qu'un une captivité
de de ce type plat et montrer qu'un
homme quel qu'il soit est un homme
qu'est-ce que vous vouliez faire
ressortir vraiment dans votre
film La la la souffrance de d'empin à
tous les à tous les moments sa force et
sa dignité certainement et puis
l'abomination que ça représente une
histoire comme ça attraper un un un un
homme et dans dans les heures qui
suivent lui couper un doigt avant même
de de lui parler
pratiquement comme ça et puis c'est
voilà c'est un homme réduit à l'état
animal et encore un animal maltraité
donc fallait parler de ça oui quel
regard portez-vous sur les ravisseurs
dans votre film un regard extrêmement
dur c'est juste des types qui décident
de gagner de l'argent et et qui sont
prêts à à tuer un individu à l'enchaîner
je je je suis extrêmement sévère le
baron a déclaré publiquement qu'il avait
apprécié le film ça vous a touché euh
oui ça m'a touché parce que
c'était je j'ai vécu comme une grande
responsabilité le le fait de de raconter
l'histoire de quelqu'un qui vivait
encore qui était une histoire
extrêmement dure extrêmement intime si
lui ne s'y retrouvait pas s'il s'était
senti ou trahi ou sali ou ou maltraité
ça aurait été quelque part une torture
supplémentaire et et je ne voulais pas
ça j'ai fait le film justement pas pour
le réhabilité mais mais en tout cas pour
dire voilà cet homme n'était coupable de
rien
aujourd'hui le baron ampin a 77 ans il
partage son temps entre la région
parisienne et
Monaco remarié grand-père et
arrière-gr-père il s'est reconstruit et
savoure sa deuxème
[Musique]
vie diampin comment va votre frère
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce qui nous a
sauvé dans tous ces événements c'est que
nous avons toujours gardé un certain
humour c'est notre éducation peut-être
aussi notre étoile le rire et le partage
donc aujourd'hui il va bien ça lui a
donné davantage
d'authenticité il est devenu plus plus
accessible plus humain plus plus proche
je me souviens d'une conférence de
presse qu'il avait donné un peu après sa
libération où il avait dit au fond je
m'aperçois que le bonheur ça consiste à
se lever le matin à prendre un bon café
à prendre une douche euh à embrasser les
siens et à partir travailler voilà c'est
c'est au fond je pense à redirigé vers
euh euh une forme assez simple du
bonheur des bonheurs simples comme la
chasses ou les vacances à la
montagne il a des amis qui sont qui lui
sont restés fidèles et vous savez ça
sert aussi ce quand on a été euh euh au
au au Panthéon et puis qu'on redevient
monsieur tout le monde on mesure aussi
la qualité de ses amis de ses vrais amis
est-ce que vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui il
est un homme
apaaisé sur un contexte familial il est
apaisé il a retrouvé ses enfant il est
on l'aime on est chaleureux on est
heureux on rit donc il est
apaisé aujourd'hui le baron travaille
sur un projet de film retraçant la saga
industrielle de la famille
ampin pour laisser une autre trace dans
l'histoire que ses souvenirs qui lui
collent à la peau du baron enlevé et
mutilé et pour tourner définitivement la
page de son ancienne vie dont il ne veut
plus
parler